DANA PERINO, GREG GUTFELD,
JESSE WATTERS, AND JUAN WILLIAMS
JESSE WATTERS, AND JUAN WILLIAM
JUAN WILLIAMS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS FIGHTING A
BRAND-NEW BATTLE TO COMBAT
INTERNAL LEAKS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKING A TWITTER
TO BLAST STAFFERS FOR THE LATEST
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURES.
THE LEAKS COMING OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE MASSIVE OVER
EXAGGERATION PUT OUT BY THE FAKE
NEWS MEDIA
IN ORDER TO MAKE US LOOK AS BAD
AS POSSIBLE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, LEAKERS
ARE TRAITORS AND COWARDS, AND WE
WILL FIND OUT WHO THEY ARE!"
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS WARNING BIG
CHANGES ARE COMING AND THESE
LEAKERS COULD BE KICKED TO THE
CURB.
>> THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF LEAKS.
SOME EXIST TO HER COLLEAGUES.
SOME EXIST BECAUSE THEY DISAGREE
WITH POLICIES.
BUT NONE OF THEM ARE HELPFUL.
I WILL SAY SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S
GOING ON IN THIS WHITE HOUSE BUT
NOT AS BADLY AS IT WAS IN THE
BEGINNING.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH LEAKING.
IT IS USING THE MEDIA TO SHIV
EACH OTHER.
YOU HAVE THE BLESSING OF COMING
TO WORK EVERY DAY IN THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
>> DO YOU EXPECT PERSONNEL
CHANGES?
>> I DO.
>> Kimberly: STRONG WORDS
COMING NOT ONLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT BUT HIS STAFFERS.
HE'S VERY FRUSTRATED BECAUSE AT
A TIME LIKE THIS YOU WANT TO BE
FOCUSING ON ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
GOALS, CAMPAIGN PROMISES
FULFILLED.
ALL THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN COMING OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, BUT THEN YOU HAVE
THESE LEAKS WHICH MAKES IT
FRUSTRATING.
>> Jesse: AS COMEY SAYS,
THERE'S A LOT OF WEASEL MOVES BE
MADE AND THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE
AND THERE'S REASONS FOR THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RINGS OUT THE
BEST AND WORST IN PEOPLE BECAUSE
HE ENCOURAGES COMPETITION WITH
HIS STAFF.
THE AN OUTSIDER BUSINESSMAN, HE
BROUGHT IN 1,000 DIFFERENT
FACTIONS.
FAMILIES, LOYALISTS, CAMPAIGN
PEOPLE, INSIDERS, MILITARY,
IDEOLOGUES, NONIDEOLOGUES.
WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY FACTIONS
COMMIT ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
DIVERSITY OF OPINION.
TRUMP DEVOURS TV AND PRINT MEDIA
OBVIOUSLY.
ONE OF THE WAYS YOU INFLUENCE
HIM IS TO LEAK.
HE IS ALSO A TALKER.
HE TALKS TO A THOUSAND PEOPLE A
DAY.
HE'S ON THE PHONE, CALLING
PEOPLE, AND HE'S EXTREMELY
EMOTIONAL AND SPEAKS COLORFULLY
AND BLUNTLY.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU CAN'T RESIST
THE URGE TO LEAK BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
PEOPLE ARE INSPIRED TO LEAK.
>> Kimberly: SO MONEY.
>> Greg: A PHRASE FROM 1990.
>> Dana: HE IS OUR YOUNGEST
GUY.
>> Jesse: AND THE INSTITUTIONS
IN D.C., THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS IN
LOVE WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW THAT COMEY HIMSELF HATED
TRUMP PERSONALLY, THE FBI PEOPLE
TOO, AND BAN LEAKED IN ORDER TO
SIGNAL THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I THINK JOHN KELLY -- TRUMP CAN
SAY LOOK AT THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA
AND DIMINISH THEIR CREDIBILITY.
OF THE SAME TIME, THERE IS FAKE
NEWS.
THERE IS LEGIT LEAKS.
THERE'S FAKE NEWS BECAUSE YOU
HAVE SOURCES THAT ARE UNNAMED,
UNVERIFIED, UNSUBSTANTIATED
COMING FROM THIRD-RATE PLAYERS
WHO HAVE AXES TO GRIND.
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE, YOU NEVER
HAVE THIS PROBLEM.
NO ONE LEAKED BECAUSE THEY WERE
ON THE SAME SIDE OF THE PRESS.
EVERYTHING THAT CAME OUT OF THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE WAS SPUN
POSITIVELY.
>> Kimberly: THERE YOU GO, A
WATER LOG FOR YOU.
DAY NOW, PLEASE TRY TO MATCH
THAT.
>> Dana: MATCH IT?
I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH AIR TO SAY
THOSE THINGS.
>> Kimberly: MONEY.
>> Dana: WHEN I WAS THERE, I
WOULD SAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM WAS ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE PAPER OR
LEADING "THE FIVE," I WOULD HAVE
BEEN MORTIFIED.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE THE NEWS.
YOU WANT THE PRESIDENT TO BE THE
NEWS.
HE IS THE NEWS.
THIS IS PART OF HIM.
THE OTHER WAY TO LOOK AT THIS IS
WITH THIS NEWS, THAT MUST MEAN
THINGS ARE PRETTY GOOD
ELSEWHERE.
WE ARE NOT LEADING WITH OTHER
DRAMATIC THINGS.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
ISRAEL AND GAZA IN THE NEXT
BLOCK.
I THINK THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE BELIEVE
THAT IF THEY ARE TALKING TO
SOMEBODY IN THE MEDIA AND YOU
GET A LITTLE BIT OF A THRILL
WHEN YOU SEE YOURSELF QUOTED,
EVEN IF IT'S ANONYMOUSLY BECAUSE
YOU KNOW SOMEONE THINKS YOU ARE
IMPORTANT.
THE REPORTERS KEEP GOING BACK.
THEY ARE NOT FAKE.
THEY ARE JOURNALISTS REPORTING
THE STORY.
THE PRESIDENT CALLS THEM
TRAITORS.
I WOULD ASSUME IN A SMALL GROUP
LIKE THE ONE THEY HAVE, THEY
PROBABLY KNOW WHO IT IS.
I THINK MAGGIE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" KIMONO FOR
TWEETS YESTERDAY WAS THAT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE COMPLAINING
MOST ABOUT THE LEAKS ARE
ACTUALLY THE LEAKERS.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IS GETTING
FIRED.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
THAT THE PERSON WHO USUALLY
COMPLAINS THE FIRST AND THE
LOUDEST AS THE LEAKER.
>> Kimberly: SO INTERESTING.
OR SHOULD WE SAY MUY INTERESANTE
OR SHOULD WE SAY MUY INTERESANT
INTERESANTE.
>> Greg: I AM NOT SURE IF IT'S
A LEAK.
I VAGUE ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING AT MAGAZINES AND STORIES
THAT GET OUT.
PEOPLE DON'T CALL UP A REPORTER.
THEY VENT OR THEY GO TO A BAR
AND THEY TALK LOUDLY.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS, TO JESSE'S
POINT, THIS INTERESTING STUFF
HAS COME OUT.
TRUMP IS THE SHOW.
HE IS THE SHOW.
PEOPLE COME OUT AND THEY TALK
ABOUT STUFF AND THEN THAT GETS
PICKED UP.
IT HAPPENED TO ME A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN I USED TO WORK AT
MAGAZINES.
I WOULD TELL SOMEBODY A STORY
AND IT WOULD BE IN THE MAGAZINE.
WHY DID I TELL THAT TO THAT GUY
BECAUSE HE GOT DRUNK AND THEN HE
TOLD SOMEBODY ELSE AND IT ENDS
UP IN PAGE SIX.
THAT I HAVE TO EXPLAIN MYSELF.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS THE PINOT
NOIR GAME.
>> Greg: I THINK IT IS PEOPLE
VENTING AND GOSSIPING.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
>> Dana: DON'T THINK THAT ONE
WAS, THE ONE ABOUT
SENATOR McCAIN?
>> Greg: I THINK SOMEBODY
WALKED OUT AND WAS JUST
DISGUSTED BY THE JOKE, WALKED
OUTSIDE, SO I CAN'T BELIEVE --
DIDN'T CALL A REPORTER BUT SAID
TO SOMEBODY ELSE, YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE WHAT THIS PERSON SAID.
>> Dana: THEY HAD THREE
SOURCES.
>> Kimberly: THEY PROBABLY
BACKED IT UP.
OBVIOUSLY HAS TO DO SOMETHING TO
MAKE SURE, THERE ARE PEOPLE
TALKING AND IT'S
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO A POSITIVE
WORK ENVIRONMENT, JUAN, FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATION, WHETHER IT IS
OBAMA OR CLINTON OR BUSH OR WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU ARE TRYING TO FOCUS ON GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES.
THIS IS A DISTRACTION.
>> Juan: SEEMS TO ME ON SO
MANY LEVELS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH.
TODAY IS THE FALLOUT FROM THE
NASTY COMMENT ABOUT
SENATOR McCAIN.
YOU SAY OH, MY GOD.
IT'S A LEAK.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
GUESS WHAT.
THE REAL PROBLEM HERE IS WHAT
WAS SAID, AND THE FAILURE TO
APOLOGIZE PUBLICLY FOR IT, SO
IT'S LIKE LET'S PUT ON THE SHOWS
IN THE ACT AND THE MASK AND WE
WILL PRETEND THAT'S ANOTHER
STORY.
THE STORY IS THE LEAK.
THE LEAKS HAVE BEEN THERE ALL
ALONG.
I WAS CURIOUS ABOUT THE LEAK.
IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK I THINK
THAT PRESIDENT, MAYBE IT WAS
THIS WEEK, THINGS GO SO QUICKLY.
THE PRESIDENT WAS TWEETING ABOUT
THIS CHINESE COMPANY AND THE
NEGOTIATORS WHO WERE TRYING TO
MAKE A DEAL ON TRADE FOR CHINA.
WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
WHY THOUGHT IN THE PAPERS?
YOU THINK ABOUT, HIS LIGHT
SCHEDULE IN THE MORNING,
EXECUTIVE TIME, THAT'S A LEAK.
GEE, I DON'T KNOW.
ROB PORTER, JOHN KELLY.
HOW ABOUT HIS NASTY COMMENT
ABOUT PEOPLE COMING FROM AFRICA,
THE CARIBBEAN, EL SALVADOR.
HOW ABOUT JUST LAST WEEK,
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
SAYING SHE WASN'T GOING TO
RESIGN.
THEN JOHN KELLY CALLED HER AND
ASKED HER NOT TO RESIGN.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU HAVE
DRIFTED SO FAR.
>> Juan: YOU ARE THE ONE WHO
WAS OFF IN SPACE AND THIS IS
WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
>> Greg: I NEED YOU TO EXPLAIN
THAT TO ME.
>> Juan: THESE STORIES ABOUT
THE WHITE HOUSE TRYING TO CHANGE
THE STORY.
THE WHITE HOUSE DOES NOT WANT TO
FOCUS ON WHAT WAS SAID ABOUT
SENATOR McCAIN.
THEY WANT INSTEAD TO PRETEND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS UNDER SIEGE
BY HIS ENEMIES.
>> Greg: THAT IS WHAT I AM
RESPONDING TO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY I AM OFTEN
SPACE.
THE POINT, THE IMPORTANT POINT,
YOU HAVE TO SEPARATE THE
ELEMENTS.
THE LEAK FROM THE LEAKING.
THE LEAK, A JOKE TOLD IN
PRIVATE, THAT'S A SEPARATE STORY
PRIVATE, THAT'S A SEPARATE STOR
STORY.
YOU CAN BE UPSET, JUAN, ABOUT
SOMETHING SAID PRIVATELY OR
OFF-CAMERA THAT ENDS UP IN THE
PRESS.
BECAUSE THAT HAS HAPPENED TO YOU
AND IT HAS HAPPENED TO ME AND IT
HAS HAPPENED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
YOU SEE SOMETHING NEW BECOMES A
BIG STORY BECAUSE SOMEBODY
LEAKED IT.
THE POINT OF THIS STORY ISN'T
ABOUT THE ITEM ITSELF WHICH IS
THE JOKE.
IT'S ABOUT HOW SOMETHING PRIVATE
BECOMES A PUBLIC STORY.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS WHAT HE
IS UPSET ABOUT.
THE PRESIDENT IS UPSET HE CAN'T
SEEK PRIVATE COUNSEL OR HAVE A
PRIVATE CONVERSATION WITHOUT
SOMEBODY LEAKING IT.
ANYBODY WOULD BE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THE WHOLE
SEGMENT.
GENERAL KELLY TOOK PEOPLE'S
PHONES WAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING, HAND SIGNALS, WHATEVER.
THE POINT IS, STUFF IS GETTING
OUT AND IT'S COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE REAL
DANGERS IS THAT IT DOES RUN THE
RISK OF CHILLING CONVERSATION SO
THAT IF YOU GO INTO A MEETING.
YOU ARE IN THE ROOSEVELT ROOM
AND YOU NEED TO KICK AROUND
IDEAS FOR POLICY TIME, YOU DON'T
WANT TO BE THE ONE WHO SAYS I'M
AFRAID TO SAY SOMETHING IN THIS
MEETING.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE A COMMENT
LIKE THAT ABOUT SENATOR McCAIN
BUT IF YOU SAY THAT'S NOT A GOOD
IDEA BECAUSE OF XYZ, AND YOU ARE
SHOOTING THE BREEZE IN YOUR
BRAINSTORMING, AND IT GOES IN
THE PAPER, IT RUNS THE RISK OF
THE PRESIDENT NOT GETTING HIS
APPOINTEES' BEST ADVICE.
>> Greg: I WANT TO ADD TO THAT
THAT I DO THINK YOUR POINT ABOUT
CONVERSATION BEING CHILLED IS
IMPORTANT.
BUT WE HAVE TO ADMIT WE HAVE
TOLD JOKES.
EVERYBODY TELLS A SICK JOKE
PRIVATELY.
THEY MAY NOT REMEMBER THAT THEY
DID BUT THEY HAVE.
WE ARE SETTING A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT.
ALL OF MY FAVORITE PEOPLE ARE
TASTELESS.
>> Dana: WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT SOMEBODY IN THE ROOM TOOK
THE JOKE.
WHATEVER IT IS THEY DON'T LIE,
SOMEBODY IN THE ROOM, THEY WERE
WILLING TO GO OUT AND DO THAT.
THAT'S A BIGGER INSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: YOU COULD SAY THE
JOKE IS AWFUL.
>> Juan: IT WASN'T A JOKE.
>> Greg: IT WAS A BAD JOKE.
>> Juan: NOBODY EXCEPT YOU
WOULD DESCRIBE IT AS A JOKE.
"JUST ABOUT DEAD," NOBODY TOOK
IT AS A JOKE.
IT WASN'T REPORTED AS A JOKE.
MY POINT IS THAT WE KNOW THE
PRESIDENT TALKS A GREAT DEAL.
HE TALKS TO PEOPLE HERE AT
FOX NEWS APPARENTLY REGULARLY.
>> Greg: WHO ARE YOU REFERRING
TO?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW.
I CAN GO ON EITHER SIDE OF ME.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT PEOPLE IN
THE KNOW WHO ARE STRONG
REPUBLICANS, KARL ROVE SAYING
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS THE
BIGGEST LEAKER OF ALL BECAUSE HE
TALKS.
WHEN I AM SAYING YES WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT PEOPLE HAVING
CONFIDENCE.
THESE ERIC TRUMP'S PEOPLE.
HE BROUGHT THESE PEOPLE IN.
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN THE POOR
PRESIDENT.
THE POOR PRESIDENT.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT.
>> Greg: I NEVER SAID POOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Kimberly: HE IS
TRANSPARENT.
HE LEAKS ON TWITTER.
HE TELLS EVERYBODY WHAT HE
THINKS AND WHAT IS FEELING.
HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
THE OWNER AND THE KEEPER OF THE
INFORMATION, SO IF HE WANTS TO
TALK TO A REPORTER, MAGGIE
HABERMAN OR SOMEBODY,
RUDY GIULIANI, WHAT EVER COME OF
THIS IS WHAT HE DOES.
THIS IS HOW HE OPERATES.
>> Juan: A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE A HISTORICAL
RECORD GAP BECAUSE THINGS ARE SO
STRANGE RIGHT NOW IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Kimberly: THERE SHOULD BE A
RECORD BECAUSE IT'S STRANGE?
>> Juan: PEOPLE WANT THE
HISTORICAL RECORD TO BE CLEAR.
IT'S LIKE THE PHONE CALL WITH
THE AUSTRALIAN PRIME MINISTER.
NO PROBLEM.
TURNS OUT IT WAS A BIG PROBLEM
AND SOMEBODY LEAKED IT BECAUSE
THEY WANT OF THE WORLD TO KNOW
THIS IS THE WAY HE TALKS TO OUR
ALLIES.
>> Greg: I HAVE WITNESSED
THINGS SAID IN THIS COMPANY THAT
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T THINK IT WAS